We know that Manitoba children,
regardless of their background,
do best when they are connected to their families and communities.
For many decades, indigenous peoples have been blocked
from being able to provide this care.
But together with indigenous leaders,
we are writing a historic wrong
and taking a major step towards investing in strong
family and community connections.
I'm really excited to announce today that as of October 1st,
our government has amended Manitoba's Child and Family Services Act
to introduce four new agreement types
to fundamentally reshape child welfare here in Manitoba.
These new agreements,
family support, kinship care,
customary care and voluntary care,
means more options are available
to keep children out of the child welfare system
while keeping their parents actively involved in planning
for their own children.
I am glad to see that parents will retain guardianship
with these new agreements.
Parents will continue to exercise their rights as parents.
Our families need to be supported through our own customary laws,
traditions, not through the court system.
You know, and I thought I would get my kids back in a year,
two years,
five years, 10 years.
It still didn't happen.
And yet I had, I had individuals,
people in power and professionals who had confidence in my parenting.
I just need a little bit of support.
There is nothing more damaging to a mother,
to a parent then taking away your children.
I know that first hand in my own personal life and the effects.
Of having been in child welfare and what that did to my own mother,
which ultimately ended up,
you know, losing her life to drug overdose.
What we proclaimed on October 1st
and the path that we are currently on here in Manitoba
of customary and kinship care agreements
keeps children with their,
their families
and keeps parents involved in the well being of their children.
That is fundamentally decolonizing work.
And so my message to families and to parents
is that we are here to work with you.
And I know that our partners
and stakeholders are here to work with families as well.